[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
and we talk about
whatever we want you guys want to know
something
what i'm buddhist oh [ __ ] congrats
how long have been you look like you're
a new wave buddhist right now with the
cane the hair
the robe i ain't even trying to do that
[ __ ]
man why are you doing it james cage
white
i was wearing like okay i have we're not
talking about the t-shirt we're talking
about the
the kimono i know but i wanted to match
this it's kind of cool denim come on
yeah yeah and i got another one i have
another one that's made out of
like ghee material like a judo one but i
bought this like
a month ago because i this is a
different thought has nothing to do with
buddhism
cowboy jitsu there it is no i i
came across me on instagram this and i
was like they get me
they get me all the time i got it it's
gonna be on my instagram next week
there's an area in japan that's really
good at indigo dye
and then they i was like what they do
denim and then i was like i want to get
their jeans
and then i saw this and i was like
that's next level
japanese denim you know japanese denim
yeah but then
with the japanese cut though just know
the song yeah i mean yeah
yeah well it's the same that's where it
comes from like high-end oh
yeah japanese people are known for like
really good genes so what happened with
the japanese do you know how
japanese denim came in effect all the
old levi's looms
from the 50s and 40s and whatnot beyond
there's no more they're all gone
the jet the last ones are in japan yeah
and so they're using the old levi's
looms
for to make the exact same jeans they
wore in the 50s and 60s they kept it
they kept it going
yeah so all the new levi jeans are like
brand new stuff water cut
and they're not they're not made of the
same all cheerios places that existed
here in norcal
done there is like one or two there's a
japanese down place in venice but you
know the jeans are like 40
for the james holy you go to japan same
thing like in a warehouse but then you
have the old levi's looms and they're
making
the exact denim probably what you guys
like from the old school stuff
yeah yeah and then it's like it's 800
you guys
this was like a hundred not eight
hundred dollars
indigo died i have another one too but
yeah that's not me
like i know the whole attire and the
[ __ ] that i'm talking about right now
seems like i just found myself and now i
want to dress like
what i am like i am it's not
it's not it's not it's a hair tie i got
to come down you got a samurai sword
let's [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] go [ __ ] go [ __ ]
let's do this what's my what's my guy's
name from
the old movies of samurai i don't know
tom cruise
tom cruise the last samurai on earth
that's what you look like right now
tom cruise his name i forgot this from
the movie street fighter not the
ryu not right not that street fight old
one okay it's okay okay it's all
japanese film
it's a japanese film called street
fighter i thought it was called street
fighter are you talking about beat
takeshi
are you talking about the [ __ ] karate
guy are you talking about i'm just
kidding
i don't know because oh okay so you know
like lately
this whole meditation and mindfulness
stuff
and like eckhart tolle and all these
like western dudes that brought eastern
ideas to
they just re just recoined the the stuff
but it's
just basically buddhism it's rebrand
it's just buddhism right
and casey made a good like observation
because i was like hey did you guys know
that this is just tau
[ __ ] taoism and buddhism and all that
and in case he's like yeah it's
they just renamed it because like
atheists wouldn't like anything that
sounds religious
right and i was like but i was like i'm
an atheist
yeah i'm buddhist i said i mean i
studied some scientology for a while
and i was like what's your theme levels
i don't know i didn't get that high
obviously come on man
but uh i was like this is buddhism
for you know whatever white people for
western civilization
scientology is yeah it's all buddhism i
mean there's different things like
buddhism
you're not supposed to talk about
scientology outside of scientology
oh [ __ ] they're called scrolling but
whatever what are you so scared no no
i'm scared for you because they're scary
this is a public there's a lot of
shotgun patreon
yeah this is public this is public
you're from paramount though
you're from paramount there's things
that i remember because it's been years
since i had been around it but there's
like things where like
was just like that's meditation that's
meditation there's things like
that was just very
eastern philosophy stuff but there's
also things it was it was
really powerful stuff but it's not like
wasn't unique to me to that it was very
to me was
buddhism for the western civilization
there's a place to get to a place called
clear which you have no reactive mind
which is a place of enlightenment
there's nothing that you say that i can
take serious because your fingertips are
red
[Laughter]
one of the crazy things about studying i
did do this thing that was
i used to and i make it up my i made up
this term myself because
a lot of scientology was like you just
you no one's teaching you anything you
just got to read books and whatever one
of their tenets is
um if it's true for you it's true for
you period i'm like okay
i'm down with that but i had this one
thing while i was doing this thing
and what happened where i went through
meditation and like i had to look i
looked at a wall one time for like eight
hours
what and you kind of like look at it
until you get to a place where you can
like
look or you look at someone for eight
hours eight hours even time longer even
sometimes
until you get to a place where you can
kind of
like i forgot what the text was but like
kind of do it forever that's buddhism
that's buddhism i'm like this is
meditation that's meditation and we're
falling asleep me and my brother
laughing we can't do it can't do it but
then when you
tap into it i i had this experience i
would call crowning whereas like my
antenna came up thing
and all of a sudden it was weird like i
can
feel everybody in the room at the same
time i can hear every conversation
your energy goes out then you walk
around it's like you know when you're
playing basketball you can't miss a shot
or
it's like that moment where you're
walking through the hallway it's like i
can feel
every molecule that you're engaged
you're like fully in it
yeah and i called it crowning it's like
and then that [ __ ] would happen to me
sometimes
i would try to do this crowning things
sometimes when i went to auditions like
let's just get
into the [ __ ] matrix and but that
kind of [ __ ] but that's
also like you said like that's like
eastern philosophy
yeah yeah so i was like well i went i
feel like i went through the journey
of a white person does
just the just that i look the part if i
fall into buddhism i don't look [ __ ]
weird
doing it you know what i mean like
because i grew up christian
and so my family threw away a lot of
traditional and whatever and in the form
of buddhism that exists
i think for most people they don't even
practice it normally or right it's just
ritual
kind of like how like a lot of
christians in europe or whatever might
just do it for ritual purposes and
culture tradition for tradition
yeah but like when you look at the
scripture and go
into it you know that most people are
just not practicing it they're just
doing it they're just doing the
the rituals the ceremonies going through
the motions just doing the motions yeah
like
and then so i never understood it my
grandma was born this way so it started
with my grandma
who decided uh that she wanted to become
christian
and then her family was like why the
[ __ ] are you
so stupid and then so she got kicked out
uh or resented
the house get the [ __ ] out
but my but then she raised my mom and my
aunt
under christianity so they didn't grow
up normal japanese normal japanese kids
they
they unders they learn shintoism and
buddhism
and then along comes me right
and then so so and and so forth so like
i feel like there's no difference
between me
and a kid that just grew up here in
america christian and then you go
through the phase of atheism
if you go against uh religion and then i
was like oh this is kind of cool how
they talked about
uh mindfulness and all this stuff and
that's how they're feeding
this group of i guess not just
millennials but everyone who doesn't
want to be
religious because when we think of
religion in the western world
we're thinking christianity yeah because
we don't have any reference point
like the religion in the eastern sense
is nothing like
the western sense of religion that makes
sense yeah it makes sense that all these
things
like like people that are walking away
from christianity
or finding mindfulness to be you know
something that they could rely on
because i feel like
for me i i'm coming to terms with the
fact that i think all people need
a belief system and not not like a
religious one necessarily but like a
belief system in
terms of how to conduct yourself how to
like strive for an ideal right
and yeah i think you know buddhism is
that too it's like there's not
necessarily a god within religion or
like taoism or whatever but it's like
there's a principle behind it that
guides you through life and you can kind
of fall back
on how to you know play the game of life
better
right well there is a need i was reading
some stuff that there is a need for
religions
in society it's always kind of whatever
you know there's something we need
to like higher than us or else we can
resort back to just kind of like
self-indulgence you know but uh
but all these religions are antiquated
super antiquated that's even kind of
what celebrities are to people i think
like we kind of like
revere celebrities almost as a like
above human level
where you're like oh this is what they
do this is what they do yeah so you
deify them
and so i think even without um actively
saying like this is my religion
people practice religious like
admiration and like
that's what i have to do jordan is a god
right this person's a god they worship
them
even without knowing right yeah it's
like a religious thing yeah talk about
the drama
or that whatever the hell we want to do
yeah we're religious without even
knowing it but i think there's like i
don't talk about it before but i was
like i think
with the internet the religion's gonna
change because uh
you know what is god but someone you ask
for questions and you don't really get
answers google
what's a church but a place of you know
similar like-minded people you know
commuting about something
with big candles yeah what's what's the
social network what's facebook what is
that
but the reddit forum but your church
your new church it's like the
church but not only that what is your
soul
but an uh uh the idea of something
that's not your body and yourself but
a a piece of you that may live forever
that have profiles
yeah it's your profile like what is your
profile online but
your soul in a digital world like that's
religion i mean i
think it's going there it's already
there like your soul is there like
you know i'm sure it's going that way i
don't know who's going to capitalize on
do you guys want to do
you guys want to form religion yeah
let's do it what we call it singularity
kabbalah
singularity singularity
today's video is brought to you by
upstar upstart is a lending site
that can pretty much get you approved
with loans
beyond just your credit score they go
and assess you
based off of like education job history
and all kinds of other ways
so that you can maybe attack your
debt crisis your credit crisis or many
other financial issues
through upstarts yeah and a lot of
people you know they're trying to when
you want to pull a loan for whatever it
could be
to buy a new computer for work or to buy
a motorcycle or something like that they
think of what are
my normal avenues and is my credit limit
on my credit card high enough or maybe
going through the bank
but sometimes going through the bank or
the more traditional methods because
it's only based off of credit history
um you might not get qualified for that
much or if you go through a big
institution sometimes
it takes forever to get your loan yep
and if you're in emergency
you need it fast and what's cool about
upstart is they can approve you in five
minutes
and once approved and you agree to the
rate you can get your loan the next
business day so here's another option of
where you can get access to money fast
if you need it
check it out upstart cause like you
might need a motorcycle right
freaking now right before your first
date you might need it now
or you might just need to pay off that
credit card loan because you're like
dude this is crazy like
this credit card i have a 30
apr outrageous amount i don't know
chinese credit card
it's a loan shark company hey man i want
the mafia to
get off my back well maybe you can get
upstart to help you out
and then you pay that off and then you
just owe
one easy payment to upstart instead
yeah so check it out go to upstart.com
off the record
that's upstart.com off direct you want
the link in the description below to
click the code
and see if they can get you a better
rate than what you're getting now thanks
i'll start
did you see did you guys watch that
other one about the cult on hbo
the val no no i heard about it though
it's pretty crazy it's kind of like
scientology but there's a guy but then
he
became a sex ring it became this is
another nexium
nexium oh so check this out the girl in
that
it's a docu-series docuseries allie mack
who's like was the right-hand
girl to the guy that's from smallville
right she's from small this is the home
she also went to the same school with me
and pedro pascal graduated my sister
oh [ __ ] so many people
bro did you go to school in the oc or
the bank
i came out my sister was like i'm taking
down facebook pictures that's [ __ ]
crazy i'm like what is it that's the one
that they were burning
yeah they were running they were
branding them so it turned into a sex
ring i don't i mean i watched the whole
thing it was like why is it always mass
suicide or
a sex thing because it's the like like
jonestown all that dude did was
he had sex with everyone's wife and then
he killed
everyone is it that serious though you
know what i'm saying is it that [ __ ]
serious that you gotta like i gotta
brainwash all these women to have sex
with them
but can't you just go to a [ __ ] bar
dog and just go no game
how likeable is that he got game enough
to brainwash a bunch like community of
people like
husband and wives like everyone loved
this [ __ ] guy wow did you watch it
yeah oh josh nothing
not jonestown but no no the jonestown is
the only thing i've watched you reported
it
on jk news when it first broke it's
fascinating i mean i
i think you know sometimes i mean i was
i was in a very cultish acting class for
20 years
well you were in scientology too right
scientology i wrote about in my book
i mean if i had a band i'd be called
susceptible to cults
but i think a lot of us are you like the
vibe though no i think
la i mean i could picture him in a cult
dude
la's susceptible to whatever culture
called religion i mean
look religion's occult you got to start
your own cult bro
you know why because actors are hella
emotional but like
not critical and again like you like
actors the stereotype is
most actors are not very argument of
people they're more like
they're more like um what's the word
agreeable they're like oh is that what
it is
i want to know more about you because
they love to study humans right so oh
tell me more tell me more
and then you investigate you're like i
could see myself doing that [ __ ]
they get into the role too much yeah
they lost themselves in a role
yeah we're ultimately people all here
there's so many people here
trying to catch something that's so
intangible yeah
and they do whatever you can to empower
yourself and be if your ideal is
idealistic you kind of
commune with other people idealistically
and it's kind of like
i mean almost all religions are like
paper thin like a paper-thin concept
that you just have to
just get on that bus and go okay she was
the virgin
and she gave birth to the savior yeah
okay let's let's go with your book i
want to read this my boy's caught from
rufio to zuko which is
like a memoir but um but yeah i
i think you know we talked like
religions i mean
i mean china is a co i mean countries
are cold i mean america is a cult to a
lot of americans it's a gang
we're a gang we're kobe we believe in
these things that are like
maybe true maybe not true but we'll ride
hard for it
we don't want to like look at it and go
hold on a second
you know because that's part of the
situation but i think in all of our
lives camp we all go through
our families become cultish to a degree
at times you know
i never had sex with my dad no so you're
not sexually dead i mean once you start
getting the sex in the cult now you've
gone too damn far yeah is that what
happened to your acting no no
no no no we never got that far but just
which was a bummer though right
it was a bomb we were waiting for that
damn what the [ __ ] man i thought the
story was gonna go somewhere
because i remember what i went to a
christian school when i was like in
sixth grade i didn't know anything about
jesus or anything of the bible i didn't
where did you grow up as
i like not nothing really like atheist
yeah i guess well atheist is something
yeah
like with almost well as he's explaining
buddhism i'm like [ __ ] i guess we were
kind of boot like you know
at least my dad was most asians are
default buddhists without knowing it
because it's just in our culture my mom
came
she's from singapore so like they were
pretty christian i think
i don't know but they're also but a lot
of our family in singapore is muslim too
so like i don't really know
but we went to a christian school i went
to a christian school and i didn't know
anything about the bible and when they
would tell us stories about the bible
i was always like oh no
man but it was also probably my dad he's
like hey son don't believe that [ __ ]
like
it's all why did they put you in that
school i don't know dude
that's confusing for a kid i grew up i
grew up catholic
and went to catholic school but in like
my
catholic everywhere i mean i've seen we
had prayers at my grandmother live with
us
we had prayers every week with all the
old filipinos coming over potluck every
friday
and so it's just part of our culture
however
i never took any of this true it was
just like this is just a story like the
good samaritan
is a story the story of jesus it's just
a story to tell you about something that
how to be a better person like fairy
tales yeah it's fairy tales
i always took it as fair i never took it
then you start meeting people and they
go oh you think this is history
yeah this ain't history what's the way
they teach
it so i went to a private i went to a i
went to christian private school
uh second grade and third grade and you
know you have like different subjects
right like math or
science social studies and it would be
like okay you just learned
that uh if you put a prism like next to
a window
the [ __ ] light comes in and it turns
into a rainbow right and you're like oh
okay cool you kind of learn about
gravity
all right put your science books away
now we're gonna open our christian books
and then you you have like this burning
bush talking to people and they're like
wait i'm supposed to memorize this [ __ ]
the same way i just memorized that [ __ ]
yeah
then it starts to confuse you because
you're like because if you would have
just told me these are good life lessons
and good stories and
like almost like aesop's fables i just
took it like that by myself
but i didn't i was like jonah the whale
was what
got me i was like i got well like what
i'm like this is kind of different from
me i was like no [ __ ] way like in my
head
i felt bad i felt guilty there was
something in the roman empire that came
up and then there was reading about
pontius pilate who's one of the guys you
say in the prayer after the homily every
day like pontius pilate did this to
jesus like i'm saying pontius pilate
yeah and i'm like this is the same dude
that we talked about in church on sunday
like he'd say his name in his prayers
like oh he was real
but then i that's when i started
figuring on a second these people are
thinking
this story is historical
fact yeah then i don't think it's our
ticket like
whatever like like george washington
planting cherry trees
yeah that's a historical fact it's just
a good lesson
yeah but he wait he didn't i don't know
if he did or not i don't know he didn't
you're ruining my world bro like this
guy i thought he had a lot of apples
yeah and his teeth is a tea are his
teeth washington apples right
yeah is is abe lincoln really honest bro
like where do we draw the line
didn't he like cross the [ __ ] river
in a boat during ice cold
that's working oh damn organization
think about those days there was no way
to fact check
that's what i'm saying it was just like
i don't know bart over at the saloon
said uh like if you sound too cool if
you sound too cool
it's probably you probably that probably
didn't happen you're probably just
saying [ __ ] just
spreading propaganda about how cool abe
lincoln was he
can you think about this though like it
was just our parents and our
grandparents generation where they
couldn't fact check
us and on we can fact check so
that's how crazy it is because them i
don't know
they just made [ __ ] up parents like
that generation and on they if they
thought something
they didn't differentiate
between a rumor the newspaper
what is said on a textbook or if they
just made it up
all of it is the same fact there's no
differentiation of fact
and fiction but even the stuff that well
if it was written it was
it was more fact than in a book or
something it was principled but even the
things that are
being written it's like how do we even
know that yeah
that's even for sure because then they
go based off of the bible for example
and they're like well it was written
it's the oldest book in
in human history that everything in it
is true it's not good
so i'm like now that's not good it's
like with the with the i think with like
the
quran and with like the jewish uh
books they're all the same yeah they're
all the exact there's only one
book right would christian yet with the
bible there's so many books yeah you're
like hold on a second which is the right
book they're all got all in different
contexts you know like
they're all over back in the day it took
so much to print a book
that it had to be pretty spot-on or true
enough
to even print it but even now now you
can do a post and you're like it didn't
cost me nothing
but even nowadays with all the facts
that are out there and all the
information people still don't fact
check right true
you don't even know how to yeah yeah
they're constantly just you know what
someone can make a lie and it's it
becomes common knowledge now like this
is the new
this is the new thing well well also
what is true
you know there's a thing of like
perception is reality especially in this
town
but even in the world like when more
people believe something to be true than
not true then that's what's true
like richard gere in the gerbil do you
know i have any insight on that i don't
know or mayor lament is taking out his
rib
it's like isn't that true yeah but i
also think like
racism is more people believe it doesn't
exist than exist then it's over
that's true that's it that's true but
it's like how do we get to the tipping
point
because it's all context right it's like
it's all compared it's all compared to
what like that's what it
really comes down to so we're all [ __ ]
right there is i mean 25 years now
25 years there's something called start
can of the day
there's something called objectivity
like something that's
pretty solid objectively true yeah yeah
but
most of the things we're talking about
is a construct of
of what humans created right so like
there's no way to
prove it what are some objective truths
gravity they're awful objects are awful
hold up though but if you're ever
if they would've really screwed you up
to school here's the prism it goes to
the light see you make the rainbow god
did that
then you're like huh that's literally my
school god did that
then why didn't you say god did they
like oh damn god did that everything was
god did that because it's almost
like easier to say when you're talking
to kids and you're trying to explain
certain things you're
it's easier it's almost easier to be
like god yeah yeah and then you get it
and then you get in the line and the
teacher goes you have a whole line of
students they're like
did god do that the kid's like yeah and
you get an a
what about you and i'm like i don't
think so i think i saw the prison dude
okay and you get an f
and i'm like right i want to change my
ass i mean god god god god
be more objective bart [ __ ] dudes
[Music]
you